>> Bret: THANKS GREG.
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT AND
GOOD EVENING AND GOOD MORNING
HERE IN VIETNAM.
I AM BRET BAIER.
WE ARE COMING TO YOU HALFWAY
AROUND THE WORLD IN VIETNAM OR
THE SECOND SUMMIT BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP THE NORTH KOREAN
LEADER KIM JONG UN ENTERED IT A
VERY DIFFERENT FASHION THAN
THE FIRST, WITHOUT AN AGREEMENT
AT THIS TIME.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS HE WAS NOT
WILLING TO GIVE INTO
NORTH KOREA'S DEMAND THAT THE
U.S. LEFT ALL SANCTIONS WITHOUT
AN IRONCLAD PROMISE FROM KIM TO
ELIMINATE THE NUCLEAR ALL SNOW.
THE NORTH KOREANS HAD AN
EXTREMELY RARE PRESS CONFERENCE
A FEW HOURS AGO TO SAY THEY ONLY
WANTED SOME OF THE SANCTIONS
LIFTED TO GET RID OF ITS BIGGEST
NUCLEAR SITE.
THE TWO LEADERS CANCELED THE
SCHEDULED LUNCH AND SIGNING
CEREMONY TODAY, BACK HOME BOTH
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS WERE
GIVEN THE PRESIDENT VARYING
DEGREES OF CREDIT FOR NOT GIVING
IN.
IN SOUTH KOREA'S D COLLAPSE WAS
VIEWED WITH REAL DISAPPOINTMENT.
WE HAVE FOX TEAM COVERAGE.
HE IS IN SEOUL, SOUTH KOREA,
WHERE THE NEWS AGENCY SAYS THE
SECURITY SITUATION HAS NOW
TURNED BACK TO ZERO.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION ON THE
DECISION COME OPTIMISM ABOUT THE
FUTURE WITHOUT ANOTHER MEETING
SET UP ON THE CALENDAR.
WE START OFF HERE WITH
JOHN ROBERTS.
>> GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
WE ARE NOW IN A GAME OF DUELING
DIPLOMATIC NARRATIVES WITH BOTH
SIDES BLAMING THE OTHER FOR THE
FAILURE OF THE SECOND U.S.
NORTH KOREA SUMMIT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP GETTING SOME
SUPPORT FROM AN UNLIKELY CORNER.
THE BODY LANGUAGE BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND KIM JONG UN
LOOKED PROMISING.
WHEN IT CAME DOWN TO THE NET AND
BOLTS OF NEGOTIATION,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WALKED AWAY FROM
THE TABLE.
>> I COULD HAVE SIGNED AN
AGREEMENT TODAY AND YOU PEOPLE
WOULD HAVE SAID, WHAT A TERRIBLE
DEAL.
YOU HAVE TO BE PREPARED TO WALK.
>> KIM JONG UN OFFERED TO CLOSE
THE NUCLEAR FACILITY, THE PRIME
SOURCE OF THE MATERIAL FOR
NORTH KOREA'S NUCLEAR WEAPONS
PROGRAM.
IN EXCHANGE ACCORDING TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP HE WANTED ALL OF
THE SANCTIONS AGAINST THE REGIME
LIFTED.
>> THE FACILITY AND ALL OF ITS
SCOPE, WHICH IS IMPORTANT FOR
SURE STILL LEAVES MISSILES,
STILL LEAVES WARHEADS AND WEAPON
SYSTEMS.
>> THEY WERE WILLING TO DO YOU
NUKE A LARGE PORTION OF THE
AREAS THAT WE WANTED, BUT WE
COULDN'T GIVE UP ALL THE
SANCTIONS.
>> A RARE MIDNIGHT PRESS
CONFERENCE, NORTH KOREA'S
FOREIGN MINISTER DISPUTED THE
PRESIDENT'S CLAIM INSISTING THAT
HE MADE A REALISTIC PROPOSAL.
>> HE PROPOSED NOT THE REMOVAL
OF ALL SANCTIONS, BUT THE
POSSIBLE REMOVAL.
THE UNITED STATES INSISTED THAT
I TAKE ONE MORE STEP BECAUSE IN
THE DISMANTLEMENT
IT BECAME CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT THE
UNITED STATES WAS NOT READY TO
ACCEPT OUR PROPOSAL.
>> AND EVEN MORE RARE MOMENT,
THE DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP SAID
HE WAS RIGHT TO WALK AWAY.
CHUCK SCHUMER TWEETED, "A DEAL
THAT KEPT SHORT WOULD HAVE ONLY
MADE NORTH KOREA STRONGER IN THE
WORLD LESS SAFE."
THIS FROM HOUSE SPEAKER
NANCY PELOSI.
>> IT IS GOOD THAT THE PRESIDENT
DID NOT GIVE HIM ANYTHING FOR
THE LITTLE THAT HE WAS
PROPOSING.
>> IT WOULD TYPICALLY BE UNHEARD
OF FOR AN AMERICAN PRESIDENT TO
TRAVEL HALFWAY AROUND THE WORLD
TO MAKE A DEAL AND THEN HAVE IT
ALL THE PARTS.
THERE IS NO PLAYBOOK FOR A
LEADER TO LEADER ENGAGEMENT WITH
NORTH KOREA.
>> I THINK EVERYONE HAD HOPED WE
COULD DO THIS A LITTLE BETTER.
THE DEPARTURE WAS WITH THE
AGREEMENT THAT WE WOULD CONTINUE
TO WORK ON WHAT HAS BEEN AN
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT PROBLEM.
>> WHAT COMES NEXT IS UNCLEAR.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS SUMMIT CAME
TO A PREMATURE CLOSE ON FRIENDLY
TERMS.
>> THIS WASN'T A WALK AWAY.
THIS WAS VERY FRIENDLY.
WE SHOOK HANDS.
>> THE PRESIDENT CONTINUED HIS
PRAISE OF KIM JONG UN AND AT ONE
PRAISE OF KIM JONG UN AND AT ONP
PRAISE OF KIM JONG UN AND AT ONI
PRAISE OF KIM JONG UN AND AT ONT
PRAISE OF KIM JONG UN AND AT ONA
PRAISE OF KIM JONG UN AND AT ONP
PRAISE OF KIM JONG UN AND AT ONE
PRAISE OF KIM JONG UN AND AT OND
PRAISE OF KIM JONG UN AND AT ONT
PRAISE OF KIM JONG UN AND AT ONO
PRAISE OF KIM JONG UN AND AT ONA
PRAISE OF KIM JONG UN AND AT ONS
PRAISE OF KIM JONG UN AND AT ONL
PRAISE OF KIM JONG UN AND AT ONE
HIM OF ANY COMPLICITY IN THE
DEPTH OF OTTO WARMBIER.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE HE KNEW ABOUT
IT.
HE KNEW THE CASE VERY WELL, HE
KNEW IT LATER.
>> EVEN LAWMAKERS WHO BACKED THE
DECISION TO WALK WITH FROM THE
TABLE FOUND THAT ONE HARD TO
SWALLOW.
>> HE LIED.
HE HAD TO KNOW.
>> BOTH SIDES ARE EXPECTED TO
KEEP TALKING, PRESIDENT TRUMP
MADE NO PREDICTION AS TO WHEN
THE NEXT SUMMIT WITH KIM JONG UN
MIGHT BE.
HE SAID AT HIS PRESS CONFERENCE
THAT COULD BE SOON, MAYBE NOT
FOR A LONG TIME.